hate your voice psychobabble here with
the Questor glowing sayin Donald Trump
right here so littell dude let's talk to
Nick talked to Nick where the [ __ ] is
Nick he's like upstairs upstairs I guess
right now he is not okay okay however
there Nick hope you got what you were
looking for inside my head yeah that was
right I should have killed you when you
were on ice Oh what the [ __ ] you want to
try for round two let's go what what are
you talking about Sam like hella sounded
like Kel out just that did I anyway I
feel or I could head back to dime ya ask
there's something wrong with you Nick I
told you I'm fine well I get it I'll be
in diamond city would you change this
Oh sucked up anyways get the [ __ ] out of
here okay let's go the Glen say babe a
look at the glow in safe babe a good
thinking of a super mutants I get you
don't give a [ __ ] about radiation that
he likes he baits and it is nipple get
hard from it okay all right all right
trying to think what the fastest way is
this way I'll go directly to it because
I can just sort through water hazmat
suit i guess that beeping noise yeah
okay okay that was really [ __ ] up that
was a really [ __ ] up
okay not going to go there i guess i go
here
this way ok
I'm just walking just walking yes I can
oh oh chase us I'm just gonna let you
know what they get there I'm gonna skip
ahead okay okay we're really there were
there um I think I'm actually passed the
border right yeah sorry about that guys
and I like sorry anyways I got my hazmat
suit on easiest way to do this oh [ __ ]
this actually have two hazmat suits
strong law of radiation makes nips hard
so we're all good okay okay okay that's
chef what is that oh it's a piece of
[ __ ] that I'm not a piece of [ __ ] it's
all [ __ ] here
what is that sort of this alright
nothing but goals so i can live here oh
man check
insulation k21 be what the [ __ ] is that
well I'm going to save this I'll look it
up later okay I just try to get the [ __ ]
out of here it's the real danger and the
waistline is getting stuck on porches
okay now the Sun it's very hot hmmm or
walk in my walk and X third film you
don't really miss anything during that
whole event I think I went against a
piece of shet thing what is this the
[ __ ] is that I thought I'd keep this
anger that's kind of interesting you
guys haven't seen this that glow inside
pitch a cyclone say what is this it's a
gun mark right that it is and I think
offices hello okay okay a lot of thunder
hear a lot of thunder
okay so this is like where the bomb
[ __ ] dropped or something ok ok so
Slavic I touch this what the [ __ ] is
this ok
she says to [ __ ] yourself we're so fast
Jesus I missed and it Donald Trump could
beat city so courageous Anna okay it
says he's like up there she really
helped i go that way
maybe the Crown's like a rock solid here
oh okay this won't see the craters side
greater bad i'll get quick save the fire
is this the world will be shown Adams
glory okay Adam will lead us all to
glorious division okay may Adam bless
you with his blue stop right there
stranger you approach Adams holy ground
why state your purpose or be divided in
his sight senator chest I'm here do you
seek division have you come I'm looking
for some Virgil bright what do you I
just need nice in truth this Virgil has
caused some concern though he came to
trade with her son a few occasions ah
you can find him southwest of the crater
ok thank you I need to speak with you
what do you need of my child
how have you survived that is Adams you
he has brought us here to this place
that is our call mm-hmm okay [ __ ] kind
of play this the Great Divide comes
hey where'd if Adams glory must be
spread to all it's in there hey this
place is dope okay well anyway that's
that oh yeah [ __ ] is agile
have a [ __ ] far back this back out
anything honey scorpion oh Jesus I
didn't know they could do that what's
that oh wow set another one [ __ ] the
[ __ ] medal
help me help me
we're heat it out like that
this is a plane chase s
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm just running to
wherever your [ __ ] he is
okay I can't [ __ ] dug it up here this
guy is really hiding
she's gonna blow his [ __ ] face off
your green so hard okay okay okay you
got this you got this not me sir I'm
here I'm here for your pizza delivery
chase s how the [ __ ] do I get up here
okay can I get him to a jack lighten up
[ __ ] up over there
chase s
suck in her running on a coward
[ __ ] he's still fighting that [ __ ]
can't tell her is it strong what a
[ __ ] badass ok ok what's your high it
says
oh god get good
hold it take it nice and slow no sons I
know you're from the Institute where's
Kellogg yeah I said that take it eat
dirt right don't you haha there's no
question Kellogg with me Inuvik send him
after me so you water you man why did
you leave you know about the escape sure
no why are you relax wait what you want
to get me never mind a yearly impossible
that would reason could you it fine know
what how I'm telling you I can help you
hmm ok you help me alright if I help you
you're going to do something for me
before it could return me to normal you
understand I think all right first
things first
yeah the world will not many it's
commonly referred to as d materializes
you in one place the relay is the only
but me know now now another's coursers
are instant operations go wrong they're
very good at work let's go well every
coarser has its embedded in it no I
don't know you are going to have to hunt
okay what do I need to listen up sure
the primary insertion point for coursers
is in the know the relay causes some
pretty would you get to the ruins Sasha
guys at the Gonski
you